une page est en train de se tourner pour
le pionnier du nouveau cirque
après plus de 35 ans d' aventure le
cirque plume originaire de franche-comté
joue son ultime spectacle au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
leur objectif depuis leur création
célébrer cet art millénaire à leur façon
l'idée c'était de faire un rêve de vivre
la vie qui nous plaisait le plus c'est
la vie itinérante avec un chapiteau de
faire un spectacle de cirque qui nous
permettait de rencontrer toutes les
classes d'âge toutes les classes
sociales dans un spectacle qui pouvait
être conçue comme un poème
acrobatie danse mât chinois ou encore
numéros comiques pour cette dernière
saison 15 artistes envahissent la scène
au rythme des saisons et célèbrent leur
amour pour la nature
on va traverser des moments de la nature
de la saison de la forêt la forêt qui
est peut-être notre inconscient à tous
de la neige du vent on va traverser des
soleils ou à traire c'est un spectacle
comme ça derrière ce spectacle musical
acrobatique et poétique un message
écologique pour que cette nature mise à
mal ne vivent pas sa dernière saison à
découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre sur la
scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines